leute heute sagen mit chips zu meinen
haaren heute ist der große tag eine
extensions komm raus und ich müsste
eigentlich jetzt schon auf dem weg sein
aber ich möchte euch noch ganz kurz
erzählen habe ich sie gut fand oder
nicht und gehe ich mal kurz ausspucken
so dass man hier die ganzen jahre über
präsentieren
meine haare habe ich mir im februar
verlängern lassen und der preis dafür
war so hoch dass ich mich zu sehr
schämen laut auszusprechen es kriegt ihr
nicht aus mir raus ihr könnt spekulieren
ich werde euch nicht sagen wie viel ich
dafür gezeigt habt denn es würde euch
und mir wehtun nicht desto trotz auch
wenn sie so teuer war waren sie in ganz
china struggle ich finde extensions sind
für ein paar tage mega cool und du hast
plötzlich links hier so geboten
lass mal dein haar herunter aber dann
kommt wieder so diese phasen du merkst
ich überall habe und das schlimmste
rüber keiner redet diese plastikding in
den hades bei mir sind so keratin
verbindungen
seit vier monaten nicht so durch meinen
kopf gehen und ich hasse es
ich möchte ich möchte meinen kopf
kraulen
ich möchte das team um einen korb trauen
kann und nicht mit seinen fingern
irgendwo hängenbleibt es macht viel spaß
und deswegen werden wir uns heute jetzt
alles rausnehmen lassen und eine doch
schon krasse veränderung machen wer mich
kennt weiß eine frisur hält bei mir so
vier monate habe ich den bock mehr also
gehen wir jetzt zu meinem absoluten
lieblings laden in köln das ist hier
nicht sponsoring ein werbevideo keine
werbung ich finde einfach nur dass es
der beste friseur in köln also da gehe
ich schon seit vier jahren hin und
mittlerweile darf mir kein anderer mehr
an die haare
außer beten
die letzten sekunden mit meinen haaren
genießen wir noch mal kurz den augen
wird beim sex wird außerhalb eigentlich
habe ich schon mal darüber gesprochen
dass ich keinen liebe ich in köln
ich würde einfach hinzu es ist
unglaublich berlin oder köln
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das sehe ich habe ein bild von der
liefer gesehen
sowieso kurze dunkle kurze haare dunkle
kurze wäre halt auch mal wieder was so
gar nicht anderes welche würde das
gesamt also ich bin es bei bt habe einen
kaffee bekommen und jetzt werden wir
erst mal die extensions rausnehmen und
schauen was da überhaupt noch so ein
haar daran ist ich hoffe genug zeigt
euch mal ganz kurz diese bonding also
trigger warnung das sieht echt ein
bisschen eklig mittlerweile aus weil die
haarwurzeln so rumhängen ich bin
wirklich ein sauberer mensch ich dusche
regelmäßig aber das sieht aus als ob ich
leise hätte dass sie wirklich so aus
extension sind voll das tracken und mein
gott das licht in seinem laden ist
richtig schön kritisch supermodel ist es
die zeit ist müssen wir uns
verabschieden
vor allem habe ich gestern so ein foto
zusammen hoch geladen wo ich so meine
haare machen das und gerd blome sie
verabschieden uns von meinen hart und
time to say goodbye
[Musik]
drei stunden später in langendorf
so ich bin jetzt kehrten das ist jetzt
meine neue frisur oh mein gott jetzt
kommt der moment ich glaube die haare
fassen um eine kopf und herzen gefallen
ist
so eine extension sind lieber raus
mittellanges haar
lustigerweise sind die noch so leicht
gewählt weil ich die gestern gelockt
haben das sieht eigentlich aus als ob
ich sogleich ausgehen könnten aber ich
habe anderen klar der mir noch ein
bisschen angst macht aber ungefähr so
was soll's werden also es soll auch
jetzt viel dunkler werden und viel
kürzer lasst uns schauen wie das so
werden vielleicht ist das ein komplett
neues leben für mich crazy so wie
möglich
[Musik]
da waren ja so nacken tut um schlanker
und nach oben kompakt wie so ein
bisschen streng sind genauso da finde
ich meine dass ein bisschen zu machst so
zu sehen sie bestimmt darf ich nicht
[Musik]
hitzfeld
und jetzt in die haare kurz nicht zu
kurz wenn die haare gefärbt glaube mehr
kann man dazu auch nicht mehr sagen
okay ist müssen hintergrund zu sehen
[Musik]
wenn man ernst sein also meine haare
sind jetzt gefährt und wir waschen
also ich muss sagen ich sehe aus wie
john cook habe es schön das klima im
hintergrund zu sagen
[Musik]
willi hat gesagt dass bönen gar nicht
schön heißt sondern schön einkaufende
haartrockner marke von bosch aeg
produkte
leute seid ihr bereit fürs tv
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo
und was sagt ihr zu meinen neuen hahn
ich meine natürlich sollte mir an erster
stelle gefällt geübte gefallen aber es
ist natürlich auch immer sehr wichtig
was die menschen da draußen sagen ich
bin endlich für euch das zeigen zu
können
die letzten tage waren sehr hart es ist
sehr hart wenn man nicht zeigen kann
wenn einem was cooles passiert ist ich
bedanke mich ganz recht herzlich bei bt
die hat das so fantastisch gemacht ich
liebe ihren laden ich kann euch den
wärmstens empfehlen
gerade jetzt wo corona viele leben eine
schwere zeit bereitet möchte ich sie
unterstützen aber das war keine werbung
nichts bezahlt ist nichts gratis keine
sorge ich bin ich schon wieder in berlin
und ich habe die mütze von kelly geklaut
weil ich finde sie funktioniert ganz gut
mit den kurzen haaren
ich kann sie auch mal absetzen mein gott
jetzt die ganze summe zur aufnahme ich
finde man sollte immer etwas neues
ausprobieren sei es sich die haare
verlängern zu lassen oder sie mal ganz
kurz zu schneiden es macht immer so
neuen typen aus ein und ich finde ich
habe jetzt auch etwas sehr französisches
hat nike zu mir gesagt sich französisch
aussehe und mit der mütze finde ich als
einen koreanischen touch auch wenn es
eigentlich eine baskenmütze ist und
damit hat mein herr umstyling ein neues
kapitel erreicht zum glück habe ich
sofort von dem professionellen friseurin
machen lassen und nicht alleine etwas
versucht schreiben immer gerne in die
kommentare ob ihr sohn mensch seit der
er die gleiche frisur trägt und dann
nicht daran verändert vielleicht weil
die auch einfach super happy seit mit
euren haaren wie sie sind oder
vielleicht weil ihr angst habt vor
veränderungen das kann ja auch sein
oder seid ihr eher wie ich dass alle
vier monate irgend etwas komplett neues
kommen muss weil man sonst in den
spiegel schaut sich selbst nicht mehr
erkennt dass es die man ansonsten
wünsche ich euch einen wunderschönen tag
und ich hoffe euch das video gefallen
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal
wieder halt die ohren steif
lasst es euch gut gehen und genießt das
gute wetter bis dahin euro
in meinem erkennbar war gerade noch noch
einen abschließen gibt es noch ein
lookbook ihr seht ein tisch deswegen
komme ich nicht dran vorbei
das ist keine schmeichelnde position